Now when you train for the Mayweather fight,
what,
first of all,
how much time did you have to prepare for that for 10 weeks to the day?
That doesn't seem like a lot.
No,
no.
I remember just getting the,
getting the message.
Do you think that that was calculated and Floyd's part?
Uh,
maybe he's a very smart guy because it seems like most of his fights or planned
way in advance,
but that one was like what?
It's a couple of months away.
Just sort of half in.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was,
was it August?
Is that when the fight took place?
And it was August.
August,
yeah.
And so I remember hearing about it and thinking of like,
wait,
August.
That's fucking really close.
Right?
Like for a Mayweather fight,
you would think six weeks or six months or something along those lines.
But I would feel like for Floyd is as great as he is and probably the best ever
in terms of boxing technique and not being hit.
I mean,
he's so elusive,
still really wouldn't want a guy like Conor preparing for a long period of time.
It really getting acclimated.
Yeah.
Um,
it was kind of funny how that all came about because when he fought Eddie in
November,
the year before,
I remember shortly after that we were at a function and I kind of pulled him
aside and I shook his hand and said,
right,
you're doing all the best,
enjoy the rest of your life.
And he was kind of shocked it was saying this to him,
but I said,
what else are you going to do you,
you're the two h champion.
You've,
you've got out the other end of this grind,
this,
this meat grinder with no damage.
You,
you're in a very small percentage and you've,
you've made plenty of money often enjoy yourself.
And then,
and then telling my past couple of months went past and then this,
the Mayweather fights start talking and I could,
I could understand that because now his grandkids were going to be financially
secure.
So it made sense because it was a big pay day.
It didn't really make sense for any other reason.
He enjoyed it.
The competition side of it.
That's no matter what you're doing Makonnen it's going to be competition.
I don't care what it is he's going to look.
How quick did you do that?
You're like,
oh,
it's been for pis.
Yeah,
I'll do a quicker.
He's just that way,
so it didn't start having a bit of a back and forth.
He's like,
yeah,
okay,
let's put the boxing and be the best boxer in the world.
And for me,
my second,
you know,
I was on the outside go,
okay,
I understand what you know that makes sense to do and nothing else was really
making sense at the time.
It's going to be damaging.
Boxing is a horrendous for to prepare for and to compete in because we're just
looking at one thing,
really punches to the head,
you know?
Of course it's a buddy's house as well,
but,
but it's,
it's so damaging.
The only justification I can see for that was,
you know,
your grandkids are financially set.
Yeah.
Tremendous,
tremendous hype behind a tremendous amount of money.
Did you think he could win?
I,
of course,
I'm a,
I'm,
I'm always gone to think that way.
You know that,
that's my mindset.
Let's that's prepare as best we can.
It's,
it's,
it's their options here.
Um,
when he landed that uppercut in the first round,
what did you think?
Yeah.
Like even when he went out to do that.
So,
you know,
we did a whole training camp and we brought in,
you probably heard,
we probably haven't even thought about.
And that was my first ever seen them against the,
uh,
recognize boxer cause in the gym we have a local guys really happened in those
sparring sessions.
Cause what we got to see,
the,
the clip that was released was Connor lighting mal analogy up.
But Paulie Malignaggi insists that most of the sparring was him dominating.
Now that's not what I saw.
Um,
you know,
when we,
when he,
when he came back from it,
like he did it a spar,
he went away,
it all broke because he had a picture,
got leaked.
And then he'd,
Paul,
he did a lot of interviews.
He was on the East Coast,
uh,
work in a show.
So when he came back,
he came back,
it was coming back to have a fight.
And it was actually,
it was a weird night in the gym because,
uh,
the,
the Fatina rotors come in,
Dana Command was a few celebrities command.
It was a fight,
you know,
and,
and the,
the referee was there.
Joe Cretae is a great guy and they did 12 hard rounds.
And I do it,
I think there is something being released on Netflix soon at documentary based
around our fight and it will have all the,
have all the rounds.
So I guess really,
yeah,
I mean we have,
of course we have the rounds.
We have to 12 rounds and a,
it's,
as far as I'm aware,
I just actually did an interview for a recently there.
I think it's the tree park documentary that's going to be on Netflix soon.
And uh,
so people will get to make up their own minds about it.
But just going back to the fight.
So what did you think though about the sparring when he walked in?
When they walked out first and I went to myself,
I've no idea what's going to happen.
I seen unboxing amateurs back home and some pros,
I,
I'm,
I'm horrendously ignorant to the boxing world.
I just,
I just don't really follow it.
And he was schooling those guys and I was like,
yeah,
but they're in a world champion,
you know,
then at that elite level.
So that night when he went into the ring of Paul,
I was like,
you know,
me and Owen are kind of like,
what's going to happen here?
Is He,
is he just going to get too old?
And then we have to scratch our heads and go,
shit,
we're going to do here.
But he came back after the rounds and me and him were gone.
We wait a second,
it's not magic.
It's still punching in its range and there's techniques.
And
so I got,
my confidence was growing,
my confidence was growing.
I knew it.
I knew,
no matter what happened,
who's going to be a good fight,
I wasn't going to be,
you know,
you could win and just,
this looks terrible.
He's missing whatever you shard and he's being made look silly.
What was it?
A good fight?
You know,
it's entertaining.
I think no one in the crowd was saying that was ridiculous.
No one was saying that was a waste of money.
It was,
it was an entertaining fight and it's going to be one of those things that I'll
be an older man than I am now and I'll be talking about the time we went into
the boxing world and for flight,
even though the night I was kind of just look at it scratching me,
what am I doing here?
You know,
that's Floyd Mayweather and his dad over there.
These are guys that,
you know,
of all the boxes I always preferred watch in Floyd and anyone else because I
love defense.
Defense to me is the most intriguing part and him and Tony and uh,
those,
those type of guys.
And that,
that's how we worked the Philly shell and it was,
it's beautiful.
It's so interesting to watch and getting on a bit,
um,
but still able to compete so fanatic this,
his whole career was defensive space.
Everybody took the shots and they were never was damaging to gym.
There was damage in fights.
But yeah,
when he was in the ring and working in the corner in air corner,
I'm just going,
what the hell is Connor doing?
Fight and flight.
This is just strange.
Even even at the beginning,
you know,
and so he used to Bruce boyfriend,
it was a different guy and he hit the bell three times.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
you do that in the rocky movies.
I remember that thing.
Ding,
ding ladies and down kind of the beginning of the ceremonial and I was like,
Oh shit that they're actually going to parks,
you know?
Right,
right,
right until the end of it.
It was still just head scratching and then,
you know,
flight coming over at the end and given us a little compliment.
You know,
he's got a hell of a Shawn and he's tough as nails and it was just,
it was a great experience.
I wouldn't do anything different.
It's the Polamalu Nrg sparring session,
which you said was like a fight.
If it was scored as a fight,
you think Connor would have won the fight?
Um,
yeah,
of course I want to say yes and we'll say,
well no,
everybody was there and the,
I had asked Dane Actually Dana,
those a lot more about boxing the media than I do and all of those guys were
going,
okay,
we have a fight on our hands here.
This is going to be,
this is going to be an interesting contest.
So yeah I buy,
I'm of course going to say,
yeah I guess people will sit around and make up their own mind but it wasn't as
one side.
It is those clips that were released where it's kind of course of course Polly
behind his shots as well.
Of course he's a brilliant boxer was for me as a trainer it was,
it was amazing looking at me and he does that.
He's put on a little bit of way easy and you still have to go 12 rounds because
after about round four was gone and he's not going to continue her cause he's
breeding very heavy and he'd been hit hard and he'd been sat down once and
whether it was a push or a poem,
shoot,
you guys can make up your own mind adapt but a lot of heavy shots and I'm
thinking he's going to be able to here by six.
So we had another sparring partner ready and I was like,
okay,
just be ready to go cause I think this will go about six rounds.
And then Paul,
you just hit this rhythm and start running his own shots and it turned out to be
a great,
a great content.
You know it's a contest because it wasn't a spiral they were talking to all
time.
Paul,
he was talking to me,
he was talking to the camera man he talked to,
he was almost better than Conrad.
It was great to watch.
Everybody had a great night and I think they bill actually bizarrely enjoyed it
like Kinda or an aid.
It's Batman.
And the joker,
like,
you know,
they both need each other children below regenerated.
It's a weird dynamic when you,
when you see a contest like that.
Well Paul,
he was campaigning for a fight.
Yeah.
He's trying to get Connor to,
to box him.
Yeah.
I've,
it's not out of the realms of possibilities real.
It's absolutely an outer realms of possibilities.
There's,
there's all sorts of crazy rumors going around the managing team and the fight
team and,
and what might happen next?
It could be boxing and cook.
It could be him,
it could be Floyd,
Floyd again,
I,
we've all sorts of names being thrown around.
Well,
one thing that happened in the fight there was undeniable.
So Konner started to fade and we've talked about this,
that the endurance issue.
Like what,
what do you think is that issue?
Well,
it certainly in,
in that fight,
you could see,
and what I learned too about it was it was just brilliant to watch Floyd how he
managed his energy.
I think it's one punch in real warm and maybe not much more around too.
He was just so,
you know,
it's such an amazing strategy.
And then,
and then switching from the usual style to kind of does hands up.
I'm walking in and,
and Connor did on load a lot on his forms,
very inefficient,
which is the opposite of what I would describe Connors fighting style,
these efficient,
very few shots,
maximum return.
This was a lots of punches and it was one of the few bits of advice I gave them
in the corner that was of any use because I'm not a boxing guy,
was let's pick a show and there's a reason why he's not trying to anything.
You don't try anything.
This is 12 rounds.
It's almost like this tree parts to a fight as one to forward his five to uh,
Asian.
Then there's nine to 12 and fly just worked out beautifully and there'd be
something that we would definitely do a lot more if we were to ever get a boxing
fight.
It was recognized that as 12 rounds,
pace yourself.
He was,
he was kind of in the MMA mode of the big shots and late the guy up.
But Floyd's the best in the world not being lit up.
Do you think it's a pacing issue and not an endurance issue?
I think it's both.
Um,
it's specifically for the boxing.
Yeah,
it was,
there was pacing and endurance in a new field.
No clench work at all.
We had a few little kind of funny clinched techniques.
We were going to try out hammer fist to the back of the head.
There was a,
well he was aiming for a decided ahead.
It was supposed to be like at the anal weed.
We played around with little stretches of the rules and we'd see what Joe
Cortese pulls up on and could we do a little,
you know I,
I'm a chunk are fine as well and you need comes from wrestling and you see him
doing kind of what almost look like arm drags and,
and,
and tie ups and stuff.
So we were trying to use that and we've just got broke every time we,
we had very little opportunity to kind of,
you know,
even going towards the back and holding the hip and hit me with one hand.
I couldn't find anything in the written rules that there were against that,
but we were pulled on the straight away.
So some of the areas where we taught we had to rest and,
and maybe make Floyd use energy that he's on used to clinch.
We didn't get that.
It was,
it was a media breaks and that's,
you know,
that's the sport of boxing,
but that's just how it is.
So he had,
it would have to be all those,
all those types of adjustments.
One of the more fascinating rumors was that there was going to be some sort of a
striking match in the octagon.
Yes.
That is with MMA gloves.
It's being talked about.
There was being talked about is being talkative that's being gone around as well
as up to Dane about that.
And he said it was harsh it.
Oh,
okay.
Uh,
well I don't deal with them.
You might heard about this.
I had heard of it.
Who's talking to you about it?
You know,
speaking with Connor and speaking with [inaudible] to talk about like you can
only trow leg kicks,
but uh,
you know,
dancing with it.
That would be the end.
Yeah.
I mean especially Lloyd did the site,
the site and Stan says,
you know what,
it's like if you get a leg kick in in that way you must face straight on so you
can check layer cakes.
If they allowed leg kicks and only leg kicks,
no head kicks.
Connor would fuck him up hundred percent quickly.
100% kager would be the first kick.
No one even understands it'd be the first leg kick.
Yeah.
Now I will say right away that Connor,
absolutely it doesn't want to do that.
He wants to fight UFC rules or boxing rules.
Zero zero interest on the high reflects just that alone.
A hybrid fight.
Just leg kicks alone.
Yeah,
he would fuck Floyd Mayweather up.
Doesn't he want to fuck Floyd Mayweather up?
He does,
but,
but we didn't want it.
The two rule sets.
It does.
It does take six leg kicks.
Just let him throw lake is just a few.
I mean it doesn't matter what fucking stands for.
It stands in either inside leg kicks,
outside leg kicks.
Just one of those.
It would be like we've,
we've allowed to,
you know,
Ireland is,
we have very good boxing history and I'm very good athletes and we get the odd
time and a good boxer will come now for spar and you know,
they,
these guys can take shots all day long and wouldn't leg kick and Dave ruin,
you know,
it's such a pain that they've never felt before.
You know,
like you said,
it just,
it changes everything very,
very quickly.
It would change Floyd's entire game.
He has no idea.
Do you remember what cool Vince Phillips fought Masato in Japan?
No.
When Vince Phillips is at the top of his game,
when he was,
you know,
a real elite boxer,
it was just starting to slide and he went over and fought Masato and k one and
Masato just for his legs up.
Sure as fuck those legs up.
It was horrifying to watch.
The only one that I remember that went over there and actually,
oh,
Shannon cannon,
Channing the cannon.
Shannon Briggs fought,
uh,
Tom Erickson and Tom Erickson cracked him with a couple of leg kicks and Shannon
actually talked about it on the podcast.
He's like,
champ.
He kept me with a couple of those leg kicks and I was ready to quit champ.
He was like,
it hurts so bad.
She goes,
but I'm pretended.
He goes up,
pretend today nothing.
He goes,
I'm in agony chip.
It's just a different pain.
It's just a stomachs.
You can get whacked in the head all day long.
And then,
you know,
most fighters won't even recognize that,
but the right buddy shot,
you know,
you had that liver or the right leg kick and there's just no grit in truth.
It's stunning for people that have never been kicked before.
It's stunning to watch WWE.
They're like,
what just happens all the time.
And if you watch like a k one match or a,
you know,
a glory match or Moitai,
it's just crazy how often they get kicked and they just learn how to absorb it.
They learn how to check it and eat it and you know,
it just takes time.
But that would,
that would be if you could somehow or another talk Conor and Floyd into a boxing
match with leg kicks.
Did Floyd actually say that?
That would be something.
It was just one of those,
while I'm talking to Connor eat,
you'd regularly trow stuff at me.
Then I'm going to be like,
what the hell are you talking?
I mean there's,
I'm always having weird conversation and this was just one of them where it come
up that there was a possibility it is,
and they were talking about at hybrid rules and he shut it down straight away.
You'll find them out.
You'll fight him off the seat and the,
they would be,
of course,
ideal.
I think Floyd is a very intelligent guy.
He's not good absolute intelligent guy.
He's not going to do that.
I don't even think you would do the leg kick.
I don't think so wider.
I think he flirts with a lot of this stuff.
I'll come over to your world,
but he's,
no,
he's no fool.
He's super smart.